I love you guys for your support I
really do I love you guys deeply so
deeply but let's do an unhelpful advice
huh why don't we do that Gilbert go
ahead helpful advice with Bobbie
dearest left Kingdom I am a longtime
listener in first-time submitter so
thanks for having me thank you I have
been become aware that I'm very
difficult person to help in a way I
believe it has to do with my father and
the way he raised me whenever he would
do something for me whether it be a
financial gift for a job opportunity or
even something as simple as a meal I
would beholden to him in some sort of
way that far outweighed what he
initially did for me for example when I
was in college my car broke down I
couldn't get to school
he sent me money to get it fixed on the
premise that I would go and work for him
on the weekends and his business since I
live in another city an hour and a half
away I quickly realized the cost of his
good deal was more than the repair was
worth and actually put me further into
debt than just having my vehicle fix
myself since then I'm not accepting any
help from him because he'll expect
something out of me in return this has
made me apprehensive to accept help in
any way even when I'm struggling how do
I humble myself and accept help from
people who care about me
PS I said be be nicer to Rudy about
helping her out and providing
opportunities for her because I feel
like she'll end up like me heard that
part
that's to you but his this guy's name is
Chad Chad there are some times you I've
I've asked money from people and
borrowed money back in the day and
people asked so like I remember this guy
Scott goes um you need money you gotta
clean my house I go how much he goes a
hundred bucks oh yeah but then I went to
his house he's a hoarder oh gosh like
dead rats the whole thing you know and
it took me like two weeks to do it it
was insane I almost died my point is is
that it wasn't worth you know the hunted
I should have done some research before
but then I've had I've asked for help
from people and they go here's a couple
of bucks don't worry about it you know
like Mencia used to do that man see
you'd never really put it over my head
he just said oh you want me to pay your
rent he had money so he's like just
[ __ ] here
you know for me it's like you know rainy
the guy we play with on war zone rainy I
didn't like I didn't like you know that
he didn't have any skins for his
character so I've been more than 40
bucks yesterday to get some skins for
his character you know and he's kind of
like what the [ __ ] I just for a
videogame you're giving me look at a
closed face but my point is is that you
know we've all asked for help
some people have conditions some don't
but it's not every time but you know
what you need we I would not not know I
would have not made it in this business
without asking for help people have
helped me yeah and I think it's
impossible to to live your life that way
that's very your you're doing a
disservice to yourself because there are
people a lot of people that give just to
give out of the goodness of their heart
without expectation someone when someone
gives you something but then holds it
over your head and then expect something
in return down the road that's not that
has nothing to do with gift-giving that
has everything to do with power playing
you and trying to strategically play
people like a [ __ ] chess piece and I
don't think that that's right but and
you are it's not to say that you won't
encounter a lot more people like that in
your life
but you will encounter the opposite kind
of people in your life as well who will
just help you just to help you and who
find so much intrinsic reward and
helping people and we should accept that
and I think it's going to fulfill you
and you know make your life ultimately
better buddy buddy Mike boy boy boy boy
boy boy boy bleah it's a little too hard
on the B and the wife why it's fine
I'm never gonna say it in a regular
sentence to anybody boi-oi-oing
boi-oi-oing
oh pretty good oh yeah there you go Chad
but Chad um that's our advice to you
accept help accept gifts it's okay guys
what a great episode I thought was fun
do you think